So let's take a look at a result.
This comes from this nice little
database that was published,
based upon this Pami paper.
Comanici was one of the original
developers of mean shift as applied to
Computer Vision.
And what you can see here is, so here's
our original image, all right, and
you apply mean shift, and,
it does a really fine job, all right?
I mean, take a look at
this brick structure here.
And you see all of those pixels
are put in the same region.
Likewise, you get this front
of this building here.
The whole sidewalk is on one cluster
with the exception of over this area,
right?
Well, that's in a dark
shadow from the tree.
You'll notice the whole shadow
has been put into one cluster,
because the system can't,
at this point know that it's a shadow.
All right?
But I think you would agree that if you
take a look at this picture here, and
you were to draw boundaries around where
the different clusters were, okay,
you would probably end up with an image
that looked something like that.
Here are some more examples of
a mean shift segmentation result.
And you can see it
does a pretty good job.
You know,
take a look at this picture down here.
All the water is put
into one cluster there.
This foliage is broken out nicely,
the islands, etc.
So if you've got
the right feature space,
it does a pretty good job
of finding the clusters.
Finally, I want to show you an example
that also comes from that same original
database.
And again, it has a nice, original
image here of a, of the mountain.
And on the right hand side
are the segmentation results.
So, the good news is, you can see
it does a pretty reasonable job.
I mean, it pulls out this section,
all of the section up here that
didn't have the snow on it.
And maybe this, section here as well.
But, notice all the texture
that's going on in here, okay?
Well it's not that that's wrong, it's
just less clear [LAUGH] than it's right.
What I mean by that is, it's not
totally clear what you're trying to do
with this picture,
that you're carving it up into segments.
That was original idea
behind the super pixels.
The idea was,
let me carve this thing up into
little atomic units that I know
don't have to be broken up again.
But, whether I recombine them, or
use them together in some way,
depends on upon the future
processing that you have to do.
So often,
what you'll do is a segmentation step to
create these broken up, these regions,
and then figure out how to process
those regions going forward.
So the segmentation then, in some sense,
is a preprocessing step to give you a
much smaller set of units to work with.